- Hello, welcome to
this slow motion video.
- Feel like I'm on a cooking show.
- Popcorn.
So we got some popcorn.
This is the microwave
stuff, hope it works.
Do you wanna light that
bad boy up actually?
- Yeah, yeah.
Isn't that hot looking?
- Yeah that's hot, so.
Do you like cooking shows?
- Yeah, I love cooking shows.
- First, add the popcorn.
- I've always wanted to do this.
- Have you?
- Yeah.
- You've never done it?
- No.
What?
It's half made.
- Now we wait.
Oh, they're going, they're going!
- See you later.
Flipping heck!
- We'll wait for one to leave,
there we go!
That was good.
So let's put one on there.
- All right, one.
- Get a buttery one.
- You know a buttery one will work.
- Yes.
- Aw.
Getting burned here!
Awesome.
- And now wear gloves.
- It hurts, doesn't it?
- Yeah.
What do you reckon?
- Ow!
Ah my face!
Ow!
- Well that looked cool, but there was
one down there that just sort of,
even at 100 times slower,
just went, and went.
I reckon we up the frame rate.
- Yeah.
- Aw.
All right, I'm gonna man the camera
'cause it's such a small frame now.
But this is at 10'000 frames a second.
- Oh!
Ah!
- All right, here we go.
- Ah, whoa!